le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
profitez des vacances en famille
lorsqu'on est porteur de handicap n'est
pas toujours évident pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite
il faut des établissements adaptés avec
l'aide du département le village de
corail de saint-gilles propose une
structure innovante et aménager la
cabane forestière a été réalisée par une
main d'oeuvre locale avec des matériaux
pays comme le bois de goyavier nathalie
gilbert et leurs deux enfants vont
découvrir cet habitat insolite cependant
quelques jours le soleil le sable la mer
faire de cette carte postale un paysage
à la portée de tous c'est la volonté du
village de corail
ce centre de vacances situé à saint
gilles est géré par le département
il propose des bungalows à tous les
publics notamment à une clientèle
sociale et aux porteurs de handicap
comme tous les matins nathalie prépare
le petit déjeuner de sa fille j'ai
préparé deux petites madeleines avec de
l'eau emma est handicapée depuis
l'enfance et ne mange que des aliments
mixer nathalie a donc apporté ses
propres repas
cette famille du tampon est une habituée
des lieux et se sentent ici comme chez
elle c'est la seule place qu'on peut
venir par rapport à les hôtels on peut
pas et la ja dans la
le mague à l'eau il ya des kitchenettes
on peut faire son repas et tout ça mais
dans les hôtels ou paypal
on peut y a pas de ne pas équiper sais
pas qui paie cette année les vacanciers
profitent pour la première fois de la
nouveauté du centre la cabane forestière
une petite curiosité en bois de goyavier
réalisés par les agents du département
l'année dernière première fois que je
vois qu'on a vu commencer à conçoit sa
ben on ne savait pas parce qu'avec le
gaillard on savait pas s'il fallait
faire plein de choses comme ça mais
c'est vraiment agréable
il ya des bancs il ya des chaises il ya
des maisons il ya tout enfin quand on
veut on peut faire tout avec le bois de
goyavier etc jaune mettre en avant le
savoir faire local et la filière bois de
goyavier c'est l'un des objectifs de ce
projet il ya trois objectifs que nous
avons voulu mettre en place en
valorisant cet espace au bord de la mer
qui appartient au département innover
avec de l'hébergement insolite et je
crois que ça réussit faire en sorte que
tous les publics et les publics les plus
fragilisés les plus précaires puissent
bénéficier de cet accueil puis
l'accessibilité on ne le dit pas
suffisamment tous les lieux d'accueil
aujourd'hui doivent quand même se rendre
accessible au plus grand nombre
c'est un peu ce que nous avons voulu
faire un logement adapté que nathalie et
sa famille se sont appropriés en moins
de 24 heures
ces accusés après c'est la chambre la
chambre moi et ma fille on dort
la salle de bain on peut mettre là
l'enfant dessus pour assise à laitages
un deuxième conduit où dorment les deux
hommes de la famille les tamponnais sont
ravis de leurs maisons provisoires
ça change et puis c'est plus et spacieux
plus tranquille - il fait moins chaud
aller et spacieux et agréable il ya
beaucoup de place à ce qu'il y soit ou
pas la mafia capella tellement pas un
hébergement pratique mais qui offre
aussi un certain standing à l'extérieur
de la cabane sur la terrasse ugo legrand
frère d'emma a eu droit à une surprise
vu un tapis diom super d'un petit tapis
pour dormir et tous mais en fait non
aulas ou relever le tapis on a trouvé un
jacuzzi le forum j'utilisais jamais
rentré dans un jacuzzi
ça m'a permis de rentrer d'un jacuzzi en
période de vacances il faut compter 100
49 euros par nuit dans la cabane un
budget conséquent pour nathalie et
gilbert ils ne travaillent pas et
préfère consacrer leur temps libre au
chevet des mains ils ont donc bénéficié
d'un financement de la caf pour payer
leur séjour
la famille va passer cinq jours au bord
de la mer un seul mot d'ordre repos et
détente à lundi l'estampé derrière et on
wilaya la chaleur il fait bon on en
profite
le village de corail propose une
deuxième cabane en bois perché à 3
mètres de haut
elle n'est pas accessible aux personnes
à mobilité réduite mais cette offre de
logements insolites s'adresse à tous
qu'ils soient porteurs de handicap ou
non le concept séduit les vacanciers le
département réfléchit déjà au
développement prochain du dispositif sur
l'île on voit que la demande est très
forte pour avoir plein d'endroits mais
partout à l'arrêt en de petits villages
où deux chambres accessibles aux
fauteuils roulants aux personnes
porteuses de handicap et je pense que
c'est ce que nous allons faire dans les
prochains mois
le village de corail propose deux
hébergements insolites
la cabane forestière qui peut accueillir
quatre personnes dont des personnes à
mobilité réduite
la cabane perchée pour deux personnes
qui n'est pas accessible aux personnes à
mobilité réduite
le prix d'une nuit en cabane varie de 99
à 149 euros selon les périodes
les personnes bénéficiant du dispositif
des d'autant libres peuvent profiter
d'un séjour financé jusqu'à 80% par la
caf pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous adresser au village de corail au 02
62 24 29 39 ou vous rendre sur le site
du département au www.cglpl.fr
m